[Music]
welcome to simple life we're honored to
have you join us today or practical risk
management steps for the threat hunter
with your host dr. James Dana my name is
Richard and after's inch I'll be mostly
in the background helping dr. stringer
so that everything goes smooth I also be
excuse me also be there helping to fill
the questions from the QA at the end so
make sure you feed us some good
questions that you have about your
stanger practical risk management steps
for the flip hunter cybersecurity is the
biggest growing field today if you do
not know dr. James Dania dr. James
Daniel has 20 plus years experience in
the industry as chief technology
evangelist currently consultant under
Street stay or network consulting
previously with compte I a certification
partners chair LTI advisor Council and
has a PhD from the University of
California Riverside for those who
aren't familiar with this former webinar
I want to introduce you to your
dashboard dashboard excuse me a little
bit of ahead Cole if everybody can go
locate their Q&A and if you would just
be so kind as to test it out this also
lets us know that our volume is working
if you have audio just type in hello and
what dr. standing I know that you're
here and you're excited to see him if
you can find that QA module they'll be
off to the right in the lower part you
can click on it and type in hello and
good morning or afternoon depending on
where you're at
see we got here good good so it looks
like you have your audio and video
they're just going to scroll down okay
excellent so uh concert questions in
there as we're going through if you hear
something on there let us know what your
questions are and we'll fill those at
the end
excuse me and we'll reserve a 15 minute
period for the Q&A at the end if you
hear something awesome brilliant
interesting insightful and you want to
share that in your social channels
whatever your social channels are
Facebook Linkedin tweet you can use the
hashtag SL webinars that way people can
find it and you'll make the most of the
way here
you didn't come here to listen to me I'm
proud to introduce dr. Jane Stanger
they'll be your hosts for a practical
risk management steps for the threat
hunter so go ahead and sit back relax if
it's early morning enjoy a cup of coffee
or tea or maybe it's evening you can sit
back with the glass of wine let's go
ahead and get dr. James on you know at
this moment to transfer right over to
him and we'll pull him up and dive right
in just a moment here it takes a minute
to pass the rights over there there we
go great and let's see here I'm going to
share my screen so I'll even share just
an application let's give a shot okay
and can you see my screen everybody just
let me know so it shouldn't a risky
business clear audio video on this side
I'll go ahead and eat myself and enjoy
thank you so much for the introduction I
really appreciate it sir so everybody
welcome here my name is James Stanger
and thanks for the nice overview there
I've got a lot of work over the years
with penetration testing and Linux and
open source Network administration
various things if you wish you can
follow me up on Twitter at James Stanger
all one word and you can also go up to
CompTIA and check out this news my news
hub it's basically where I put together
all the fonts that I've been doing you
so you can follow me and what CompTIA
are up to I also want to point out that
you can grab this PowerPoint slide deck
I'll make a link available to you so if
you want the slide deck you can have it
so I'm curious folks just from a
perspective of curiosity where are you
in terms of your job tell me what you
are you an IT worker already in the
field are you a security worker cyber
security worker or are you looking for a
job already just curious to see where
where you are so if you could put that
into the chat window that would be very
helpful for me
so thank you very much for doing that so
over the years folks let me get started
here over the years at CompTIA we've
talked very diligently with people in
the industry both in companies that are
not necessarily tech companies but use
technology to do their business I'm
referring to banks I'm referring to
educators I'm referring to governments
around the world India the United States
UK name that we talk to them what you're
looking at is a very busy slide there
right and these are just examples of a
few of the people that I've talked with
in about cyber security and in this
particular time we have a lot of
changing tech that is impacting the
security posture of companies let me go
over the slide just a little bit
starting up at the top left is where it
says the evolving endpoint the Internet
of Things it is not coming it's here
it's been here for some time
and the endpoint has changed by the
endpoint back in the day I'm old enough
to remember the endpoint was the pc made
even a terminal right then ten years ago
the smartphone came along 10 12 years
ago the IOT world so cars are now I
enabled everything is IP enabled that
has changed the endpoint we have with
the advent of this and a dissolving
perimeter if you look over a little bit
to the right where it says top right
words is dissolving perimeter back in
the good old days you pretty much had
that physical demarcation between the
good guys and the bad guys and even
though we have plenty of insider attacks
you know over the years we've seen that
there was still a perimeter that was
kind of brought a certain kind of a
surety a certain kind of certainty
that's over with the advent of edge
computing with Internet of Things
Internet of Things devices tend not to
just communicate with you know they
cannot just start communicating at your
wearable clothing or with your car then
communicate directly to the company that
created it they come necks with tons of
quite a few intermediary devices
intermediate devices that's called edge
computing Micro data centers for example
micro clouds so with the evolving input
and the dissolving perimeter with the
advent of the cloud there's no longer
that defend defined firewall yeah
firewalls are still important they're
table stakes they're still important but
that's changed the other change is that
every bit of traffic these days is more
and more encrypted all the time
therefore it makes it it's made it more
difficult to analyze that day and that
data and find out what's going on so
data and motion that is encrypted has
changed the game again we've got cloud
and mobility and bring your own device
BYOD we have shadow IT shadow ideas
basically this shadow IP is where an
organization within your company same
marketing or sales basically says we're
going to source our own IT solution
directly rather than working through the
traditional IT department shadow IT has
generally been considered a bad thing
it's like well as the IT or the security
professional I know what I'm responsible
for but now what's happened is you have
a decentralization going on where
companies are basically going well go
ahead and source the best solution
because it's available in the cloud you
know you can inform IT about it but not
necessarily work directly with them this
creates a certain amount of uncertainty
at times if it's not managed correctly
so more and more decentralized decisions
are made the question becomes are these
security professionals and the IT
professionals properly communicating
with all of the divisions so they know
exactly what kind of information
technology solutions are happening in
the first place then we have privacy
becoming more and more of a business
concern if you do business in the youth
in Europe you're gonna have to worry
about GDP our GDP our is a law that was
passed where as I think it's in Mayors
in April of this coming year if you do
not take steps to define the privacy and
to protect the privacy of the
information that you have you get major
fines this is a
important because if you do business in
Europe you have to follow GDP are so you
don't have to just live there I don't
live in Europe so what do I care well
actually we do business it CompTIA with
a lot of Europe therefore it's a problem
staying with anybody in India these are
examples ok of how the landscape has
changed and the question becomes how do
we manage this risk because more and
more it is not about how much money you
spent on security I've had many
discussions over the years well we spend
200 million or 10 million if it's a
small company or three hundred thousand
or we spend a percentage of our gross
national national product a percentage
of our revenue on security that doesn't
matter anymore
nobody cares about how much money you've
spent on security what they care about
is how do you have the ability to pivot
resources quickly and effectively by
doing risk management so what's
happening more and more is because
attackers are able to compromise system
is easier because of all of these
factors here affecting the security
posture you have to come up with
meaningful company specific company
custom metrics I you can use the word in
this spoke it's a fancy word for
customized so that you can say here are
the controls that were implementing and
here's the return on investment and you
have to work with the board and with the
CEO and the CIO to basically say here is
our risk management process and here's
how we're going to avoid communication
silos because hackers thrive in
communication silos it's kind of like a
kind of a weird example here it's kind
of like rats in a building they love the
little spaces where nobody goes they
love to hide there they that's where
they set up home right hackers are kind
of the same way whenever there are
little areas where people are
communicating just fine but there are
little forgotten areas that's where the
bad guys tend to show up so we need a
new approach to risk management that's
custom tailored to your organization as
a security professional your job
is to combat these asynchronous threats
these new threats and to identify
indicators of compromise and then find
ways to pivot resources so that those
compromises don't happen and indicators
have compromised very important concept
basically means evidence left behind by
an attacker any attacker this is this is
from a concept that's been around in law
enforcement in an IT for a hundred years
it's called Locard's exchange principle
it's an old principle and it simply
means this whenever a bad guy comes in
to a crime I don't care if this is a
physical crime on the street or a or a
cyber crime that person comes in and
brings things to the scene and will
leave things behind and it's our job as
security professionals to identify those
things that are left behind and at which
our indicators of compromise and then
learn how to take action doing so helps
our risk management stance it helps our
risk management process it also allows
us to set up so that we can ensure the
privacy of data in our companies gotta
keep our company data private for a
couple of reasons one it's our company
data and our data is is you know the
identity of our company and it's the
value of our company data is also again
through law enforcement and through
rules and all sorts of things and our
customers very important to keep
keep safe and so this is very much a
business process sort of thing and risk
is really where you take the processes
where you take the technology right
where you take the people and put them
all together and do it right so the
older risk management strategy folks it
has to be compliance if you're a company
that takes credit cards
there's PCI at least in the United
States you have to follow certain rules
there are many companies that have been
hacked recently starting three years ago
when Target was hacked in the United
States they were PCI compliant they they
had complied to the rules they there are
as a hospital that I know that got hit
by ransomware and they paid the ransom
they still lost all their data it's a
long story
healthcare people they follow all sorts
of rules worldwide in India you have
your own laws the United States has
their own laws Germany has their own
there are companies over and over again
that have followed the laws through the
letter they still get hacked a more
modern approach in addition to
compliance in addition to following laws
obviously is this activity of threat
hunting so for those of you who joined
in it's like well when is he going to
talk about threat hunting here we are it
focuses on the ability to pivot
resources and take action based off
indicators of compromise and more
importantly you think proactively you
already assume that the that your
company has been hacked and you look for
these indicators of compromise so it
really starts with human judgement I've
been asked many times hey what's the
killer app in regards to mismanagement
or threat hunting and and my answer is
you your brain critical thinking the
value is in the person not the software
this is generally not something that can
be automated
we have great automated tools and I
realize artificial intelligence is on
its way it's here in many cases it meant
right now the automated approach of
intrusion detection systems if you're
using the open-source tool called snork
for example or if you're using a you
know one of the great vendor products
that are out there there are many that's
an automated tool that brings you to the
table it helps you but does not replace
and
active brain smart brain looking around
and looking for these gaps that I'm
talking about and so they're proactive
they're not reactive they don't focus on
alerts or or virus signatures or
firewall rules or anti-intrusion
detection signatures they focus on a
threat intelligence the question becomes
is threat hunting kind of a buzz phrase
is it something that okay that's a
little tip it's an interesting little
idea but is it real well it actually is
something you can go into job
descriptions and find references to the
idea of the kill chain
excuse me idea of the thread under the
thread hunter focuses on something like
the hacker lifecycle if you've heard
that phrase before the hacker and life
cycle or in this case the concept of the
kill chain Lockheed Martin employees
years ago came up with the concept of
the kill chain they didn't really come
up with it they kind of stole it from
the I think from the United States
military it was a concept that the
military used and a bunch of IT workers
and and security workers at Lockheed
Martin aerospace company and back in
2010 coined the phrase kill chain for
the rest of the world they borrowed it
it's still a pretty valid model it tends
to be a little perimeter focused it kind
of doesn't take into as much
consideration that idea of that we have
that the firewall in many ways has
changed because of the cloud but it
still is a very relevant idea of the
hacker lifecycle it focuses on finding
the advanced persistent threat and the
persistent threat folks means an
attacker who comes into your company
long term in many cases we've seen
smash-and-grab kind of attacks denial of
service attacks for example or times
where the attacker revealed themselves
as an attacker by revealing important
information from movie studios like Sony
or whatever the real problems
folks are these low and slow attackers
who have persistent threats that are in
your system and you're just not aware of
them they're flying below the radar
they are basically some
buddy and my favorite analogy is in the
you know traditionally if somebody were
to walk up to your house smash a window
run and grab something and run back out
right or your apartment right that's a
smash-and-grab idea the advanced
persistent threat person it's much
creepier it's much more dangerous
imagine somebody sneaking into your home
and kind of living in the home with you
and you're not aware of it that's what
that's what the companies today starting
in 2010 2010 are worried about and this
hacker lifecycle is described in in the
cyber kill chain in seven steps from
reconnaissance to weaponization to
delivery of the attack exploiting system
installing and further systems obtaining
command and control spreading to other
systems and then they basically I don't
know what that's all about
sorry let's start over again so the idea
folks is that you have a cycle of
attacks there's another company a person
I know for example he talks about the
hacker life cycle as reconnaissance then
they attack systems they penetrate the
systems they move laterally from system
to system they take control and then
they start stealing data and that's
called egress then they cover up their
tracks so there's a whole cycle here
threat hunters have to learn these types
of cycles a friend of mine in a major
provider and a major retailer in the
United States put together this very
good matrix it's I didn't come up it is
I'm not that smart but he basically said
how can we find the attack lifecycle
from the initial compromised to where
the hacker establishes a foothold where
they escalate privileges you know one
account to an administrative account a
normal account to an administrator where
they do internal reconnaissance where
they move laterally from one system to
the next and they maintain their
presence and complete their mission
that's another example of a hacker
lifecycle very similar to the cyber kill
chain what he's doing is he's
customizing the hacker lifecycle to his
own company he he realizes that the
hacker lifecycle is a generic concept
you have to customize it to your own
company and then he basically puts
together mitigating
concepts mitigating controls I need to
detect and respond to each of the steps
this is what a threat hunter does this
is what people who are really doing risk
management do all day long they don't
just say ok what are the important
controls what are the software vendors
selling me or what is it cool to
implement or what am i hearing about in
the street you have to figure out your
own company's problems and then apply
their controls correctly you can use all
sorts of cybersecurity frameworks there
dozens of them out there hundreds really
there's the NIST stuff from the United
States there's Co so there's there's
many there's ISO worldwide standard you
have to customize these things to your
own company because each company's
different and if you just apply a
generic rule you're going to be in
trouble so where does this fit in I
already talked about lockers exchange
principle and I'm going to move a bit
faster now what does this mean you have
to apply and map your controls by
controls I mean let's say an obvious one
is a firewall or intrusion detection
systems or sins right security
information and event monitoring
software and you have to apply these
resources to your essential resources
those essential resources are different
from company to company it might be that
SharePoint Server might be that
WordPress server
could be ecommerce stuff database
whatever and then you have to apply
processes properly this means that as
you are a risk manager as you're a
threat hunter you no longer are just
that cowboy coming in like Clint
Eastwood I love Clint Eastwood movies
but you're you're not coming in as a
movie cowboy anymore
you're not just Gandalf the wizard or
the Guru you are now the cyber detective
more and more as I talk to people in the
industry you're in the cyber detective
you deduce ish and find problems you
kind of to use a Western centric
metaphor you kind of Sherlock Holmes or
you are the guide imagine that's me
climbing Mount Snowdon in the UK you're
you're following a path and you're
helping people use the right tools so
they can you can serve up the mountain
or go along the trail
the team captain I'd follow you
footballers out there or rugby or for
that matter cricket you're the team
captain where you coordinate and pivot
resources those are the newer mindsets
of the threat hunter the threat hunter
then learns how a business works and I
can't emphasize that more you learn and
you gain a clearer understanding of the
end points on the system that means all
the IOT devices all the phones all of
the IP all the desktops etc you learn
networking best practices that
constitute a network so you then learn
about how the network works endpoints
and also network infrastructure more
importantly you learn how information
flows from one system in that network to
another because that's what hackers are
doing to you and you find out what's
going on
so you're basically creating hypotheses
and you're engaging in a kind of loop of
thought and then you look and you
investigate network systems or endpoints
to look for patterns and you look for
indicators of compromise some people
call it tee tee tees I call it
indicators of compromise and then you do
some analytics and you start over again
and you look through the infrastructure
of your system you look into the
developers if you have a company that is
focusing on code developing but then you
need to make sure how those code
developers are working so you implement
security on your data so you and that
information flows and then as you focus
on the technical elements that allow
that information to flow and where it is
stored you you then learn how can that
information can be interrupted and more
importantly manipulated then you look
for new network traffic you look for new
processes on the system dropped file
these are all examples of indicators of
compromised connections to strange
places at strange times or strange
places at normal times you the threat
hundred then reports these types of
issues if they if he or she feels it's a
problem to the security offer or secure
Operations Center that's what a sock is
secure Operations Center you work with
Blue Team and Red Team that's supposed
to be read to you not read team sorry
about the typo there
you work with management and the board
and you suggest solution most
importantly a threat hunter looks for
what I call interest disease that's a
fancy word for gaps you look where in
between places where where one
technology and another connect here
gonna give you a couple quick examples
most obvious examples instant messaging
and or email and people where people
that's what I mean by neat space you
know us right and cyberspace converge so
a business email compromise where
somebody fishes the CEO or more
relevantly the CEOs assistant and gets
information or is able to conduct a wire
transfer any of those sort of things
it's where I internet control dust real
control systems and SCADA systems that
control physical devices factories
refineries utilities interconnect with
cyber tools or with computers
that's where hackers go and attack
physical access to a building where
people walk into a building that's where
there's gaps can form and that's why we
put biometrics in place or whatever to
try to control those gaps there are many
different examples that I won't go into
but this this concept of interstitial
security of in between places very
important thing for where the threat
hunter manages risk so I'm gonna hear it
do you think that spread hunting is kind
of a buzz phrase to you or is it a real
job role or activity just curious about
your opinion give us your opinion give
me your opinion and then take some time
after this presentation and look up that
concept of threat hunting in the job
bulletin boards that you know of and
they stayed here at Dyson monster and
indeed calm it's all around so critical
security skills are the ability to
identify patterns pattern recognition
data analytics where you analyze and
enumerate networks or you analyze and
enumerate issues you do vulnerability
analysis so you use a tool like Nessus
for example or my favorite open bas open
boss there are various tools that you
can do to conduct
vulnerability analysis and ten tests and
then this is where friend honey comes in
it's where you're combining red team
pentesting with blue team analytics that
makes you a threat hunter there's a
little bit of data forensics there you
don't become a data forensics specialist
but you do take a look inside of files
for example the netstat command I'll
just use that as an example a Trojan
analytic system will often take over
that command and others well it looks
like it's behaving normally but it's
actually compromising security and
hasn't Rochin in it might be an illicit
server that allows hackers to come in
and attack a particular system and take
it over and steal data these are
examples of the kind of forensics that
you're gonna need to do be able to do on
a Linux on a Linux system but on your
networks so you get a deep understanding
of how systems work together in your
environment if this is not a theoretical
understanding it has to be practical
based on your own company so for example
accounting and human resources you
basically look into what they're doing
and how it's working and what could go
wrong you look at installed systems
especially SCADA systems which are the
that's one of the technologies that
makes it possible for automated systems
like robots for example that are on a
factory line to work together so you
understand how the process of your
business works and you also bring
something to the table yourself you need
to understand how to resolve incidents
you need to understand how to look what
I say look around the corner of a
problem in other words you you look at a
situation and you say hmm tomorrow I can
see where that's going to become a
problem and you assist teams if there
are already existing blue teams or red
teams I work with a lot of small
businesses where it's one or two people
wear a lot of different hats one or two
people I have to add sometimes become
the pen testers sometimes the other that
same person has to become the analyst
sometimes that person is a one person
security operation center if you work
for a larger company then obviously you
have different team
but it's the understanding that you
coordinate and assist with teams to help
improve security so a spread hunter
already assumes you've been hacked it
sees that network as a hunting ground
and I want the picture of a whole
environment a threat hunter does not
believe that security is good enough
this is a little survey we did there are
a lot of IT workers out there who kind
of think a we're done we're fine you're
not if you have that attitude you're
probably in trouble so you have to take
along this observe and orient yourself
and decide you have to take this
basically approach where you're
constantly thinking observing and
orienting yourself and you decide what's
working and what's not and then you take
actions to apply skills you have to be
very aware of your world this is I don't
know if you can see this through the
resolution on your screen but these
scuba divers are not situationally aware
they're saying hey everything's great
and do you see what's behind them a very
very large shark this could be
photoshopped doesn't matter the point is
as you are an IT worker are you
situationally aware have you managed
your risk to where you think
everything's fine and you really are or
is there a big hacker or big shark
behind you lurking in the deep so you
have to find the context and understand
your operations and so you engage in
threat intelligence that simply means in
a sense you go out there and find out
for the systems you have in your network
what are the most obvious incontinent
I won't say the word obvious what are
the most dangerous threats and how can
you counter them and by countering them
you can apply controls or you can say
well we're going to do cyber insurance
instead of so you could basically say
well we think that's going to be that's
going to happen and I'll take off that
liability and I'll defer it to insurance
or if there's a liability or a problem
there we're going to implement a
security control to make that risk go
down you can engage in behavioral
analytics we have noticed over the years
all the people that I talk with that
end-users obviously are a major if well
they're the major target so you need to
engage in user behavior analytics in
your company to make sure that to
identify
where those attacks are coming in the
most and then you can educate users you
can change processes business processes
so that that problem is lowered that
risk is lowered so you use informed
hunches and you have an innate sense of
curiosity because you don't I get again
you don't want to have somebody come up
behind you like a photo bomb that's a
term where somebody gets into your
picture and does something behind your
back you don't want to have that happen
in a hacker sense here's another example
a couple of footballers were taking a
picture in the Queen of England photo
bomb as you engage in threat hunting you
basically engage in some interesting
terminology the customer is the
beneficiary of the attack if there's an
attack going on on your company and
somebody wants it to happen that
customer might be somebody who's not
even technical they might employ a gang
of people to attack your company so the
adversary is the operator that person
could be an internal worker a
disgruntled unhappy internal worker it
could be a gang of outside workers and
so what they're going to do is they're
going to use some form of infrastructure
maybe your own company infrastructure
they're going to use their own to wage
the attack then they are going to use a
capability some tools to wage the attack
and then there's a victim that would be
you so that customer is the beneficiary
of the attack it might be the same as
the adversary but oftentimes they're
separate these are the kinds of terms
that are that are used in the concept of
threats something there are companies
that are more mature than others in
threat hunting this is something I stole
from I used from a fan's they have some
very good articles about what threat
hunting is sans is a security
organization and they basically put
together levels from zero all the way to
four I would argue that most companies
are at the zero or one level if you're
really lucky you might be at the hmm two
procedural level okay
most companies are happy if they have
automated alerting and most companies
really don't have much of a routine and
I would argue that more and more
companies are getting up to hmm one
right where they incorporate a little
bit of threat intelligence and they have
a little bit of routine their goal is to
get as high as possible but it's very
costly okay so it's the hunting maturity
model and the whole idea folks is that
you basically move to create an
architecture and move from a passive
defense to an active defense and to be
the ability to gain intelligence and
take on an offensive capability against
the hackers there are various types of
threat or hunting out there folks user
centered which is where you look at the
job responsibilities of people then you
see well the more important the
responsibilities the more likely that
there's an attack or the more likely
that a successful attack could bring the
company down so you focus on problem
users or a problem process is focused on
users and then you try to solve the
problem
another way to do it is you focus on
capability what's the business function
of the system what's the business using
and you try to solve it there's
infrastructure where you focus on the
equipment
I find capability is very useful as well
as user and there are various reasons
why you would approach any one of these
three user capability or infrastructure
but I find that the user centered is the
most useful at many times I'm running
out of time so I'm gonna move on here a
little bit what are the hackers after
well it depends on your company right if
your company is focusing on a certain
thing of value they're going to go after
that or at least the processes that
support that thing of value oftentimes
they're after personally identifiable
information so they can sell it on the
dark web or they can further manipulate
the company accounts information they
want to control SCADA systems to either
wreak havoc or to engage in ransomware
to make your company pay a lot of money
to get their systems back or they're
after a company's reputation they
collect information a good threat hunter
collect information from multiple
resources and turns what I was talking
to one person who says well there's so
much information it's like a sinkhole
you just kind of get lost in it you turn
that sinkhole
of information into actually very useful
actionable data so you manage risk
through deep packet inspection that
means you get into the packets and then
you are good you investigate
architectures you gather intelligence
and you do behavioral analytics and
vulnerability data and look for
indicators of compromise and then you go
into this loop here as a meaningful loop
it's not an infinite loop so it's a loop
that basically allows you to engage in
proper thread hunting so the software
that you might use helps you look at
trends it looks inside of IP sessions
but it does more than just show you a
bunch of data it then turns that data
into trends and information so it gives
you a dashboard of the network it
reflects the heartbeat of the network
and and it finds that you find out who
is talking to whom and where and it
creates context when it comes to risk
management and security you need to
engage in the smart use of visuals this
is a picture that I took while I was in
Scotland here a couple of months ago
it's a place called the Quran it's a
really neat hike and you can see there's
a very rough trail that goes up to this
little place called the needles now this
is yeah this is the needle
take a look at the little map there
where it says the prison right then it
says querying and needle right which is
most useful to you as a hiker well the
map is very useful because it shows a
trail
it shows the features the picture could
also be useful because it's very
difficult to tell from a map exactly
what something looks like you can tell
from the topography or the topographical
map that the other closer the lines are
the the steeper something is but
sometimes the picture tells a thousand
words or is more useful than the map but
you can't use these in isolation I'm
coming up with an analogy a good
visualization tool for a risk manager or
a threat hunter combines that
topographical map idea with a picture so
that you can come to a quick
understanding of your network and
understand interconnections and once
again pivot resources and make decisions
this allows the board or the CEO or the
CIO to quickly make decisions about how
we can help control the hacks that are
happening and I won't say stop the hacks
it's really more managing them and
trying to stop trying to manage them
away rather than just stop them which is
more useful in your opinion if you
wanted to show somebody about a
BitTorrent illicit BitTorrent server in
a network a packet capture that
Wireshark packet capture or this other
more visual tool from a tool open-source
tool called ether 8 you can download it
either a torogai think I would argue
that if you wanted to show somebody who
is less technical this kind of picture
saying look there's a lot of traffic
here the larger the circle the bigger
the traffic and we know where it's
starting and we know where it's stopping
that's pretty useful visual
visualizations so the more you visualize
risk for your boss
the more you can look inside of IP
sessions and then get information and
then show connections and explain the
business you said explain the business
issue at hand that will allow you to get
the resources you need it will allow you
to do your job better because even the
CIOs of companies sometimes are not
interested in that
technical issues they want to focus on
solving the business issues so with
visualization this is an open-source
tool called cacti and what I'm trying to
show is that this allows you to combine
kind of that topographical map approach
with a visual that can show trends in
this case you have a trend of where
traffic pretty much as usual will go
from you know this is 1600 to 1800 1806
in the afternoon right to twenty hundred
note the traffic is staying the same and
then it goes down at night and then it
starts coming back up right during the
day as you might expect I would argue
you know at 10 o'clock or 2200 which is
if I can get it right here
sorry 20 20 is the 8 o'clock 2200 it's
interesting that traffic would stay that
high you know this is log in traffic
requests per second a little a little
high there that's a little suspicious
right but take a look at the next one
here this is an example of a vlog in
request that I get i sanitized it the
idea so that you couldn't tell a company
that I was working with notice that you
have at 9:20 in the morning you have a
lot of requests unless at 10 o'clock
that break time for some companies maybe
11 o'clock a bit of a break notice that
you have you know major things majorly
going down just before noon and then
starting again right so clearly there's
some sort of event here but is it lunch
or whatever you have to through your
visualization map this product excuse me
this visual to how your business is
processes your businesses your business
works this allows you to identify
patterns and do user behavior analytics
this is interesting here I saw you have
a 1600 traffic going way down right left
because people are going home you know
by 20 hundred people are home midnight
right you can end a Wednesday notice at
8 o'clock the traffic starts up again
notice that little anomaly there right
around I would argue what about 2 3
o'clock a little blurb that little blip
here I find that really interesting that
was an indicator of attack that was
somebody coming in well after business
hours and doing some interesting
things we were able to identify that as
a threat hunter you look for various
types of compromised by intelligence in
other words you go out and say well we
have these types of systems in our
company that we think are the highest
risk let's say some WordPress sites so
we can go out and do intelligence or
behavior based analytics they're both
useful they're one that's not
necessarily better than the other
intelligence means well I've got a
particular version of WordPress I'm
gonna go out and find out for that
particular version of WordPress what the
hackers are doing to it lately
what attacks are available that's a very
useful thing but you can also look by
behavior and see well who's logging on
who's not logging on who what accounts
are being used that's more behavior
based they're very useful and you then
you ask yourself what the adversary is
doing well do we is somebody conducting
scans of the system reconnaissance are
they are we in the middle of an initial
compromised our people moving from one
system to the next laterally and taking
over systems are they stealing
information the fancy phrase for that is
data egress so there are two ways to go
about doing this
so with behavioral analytics you can do
network behavior analytics kind of like
what I was showing earlier showing
traffic anomalies or traffic patterns
and they could look at user behaviors
you know how are specific users working
and you can model those increasingly
we'll see artificial intelligence help
model data a user behavior and then we
can take that information and start
making decisions and AI one day I'll
start making decisions for us I don't
think it'll replace our jobs necessarily
I think it'll at least in the short term
it'll simply help us so moving along the
baseline that you will set up is where
you do an inventory of various systems
and devices in your in your network
these devices or endpoints are also
network connectivity devices and of
course the resources that you use and
buy resources I mean let's see yeah
basically you're using resources that
are important to your system so you do a
software inventory as well not just a
physical one but layer seven is very
important the applications and you
configure you secure configurations etc
and move on this is an example of
baselining then you look for outliers
you have to ask yourself are those
outliers is that outlier important or is
it just you know something to ignore you
you have to figure that out yourself and
a threat hunter doesn't just ignore it
or accept it it has to go in and
investigate it so you engage in endpoint
monitoring now some of the problems with
endpoint monitoring or something that's
very controversial some people think
agents well they don't take up much room
or much time but there are a lot of
times where security workers want to
install agents for antivirus and agents
for monitoring and agents for intrusion
detection after why I got so many agents
they can conflict with each other they
can cause problems they I don't know if
they can slow system's down it's
happened but you have to basically
sometimes there are dissolvable agents
by the way in other words they work for
a while then they just kind of destroy
themselves and good guys and bad guys
use these but the question becomes in
what way will performance be impacted
either your performance as a as a dread
hunter as a risk manager or even the
performance of the machine well what are
the killer apps of the threat hunter
well you are there are other systems
that I was talking to a threat hunter
and also to an analyst who said hey the
Excel spreadsheet this is the killer app
because it allows me to create tables to
identify to the CEO what the problems
are but there's virustotal squirrel data
and game end top very useful tools and
top a very nice little tool that allows
you it's not considered a security tool
particularly but it is very good at
showing trends over time it can also saw
a connections of networks that sort of
things so you can engage in hypothesis
based threat hunting as well as
situational threat hunting hypothesis
meaning well and see we have a
particular situation I'm going to make
an educated guess situational is where
you basically say well are
company has recently purchased another
company that other company has a lot of
SCADA systems or a particular type of
system let's investigate that because
that's a new element coming in we have a
new situation let's go take control of
it well what happens next you make
recommendations next to the security
operations team to the incident response
team and remember the incident response
team is not necessarily just all techies
that's going to be a PR person in their
legal representatives of HR certainly
representative from the CEO or the board
you'll be talking to these in a larger
company the chief security officer
always the CEO and the board one of the
things I'll make a real quick applied
example was once talking to a person who
was working on a conveyor belt
controller system that was compromised
by ransomware he discovered that that
this controller system which controlled
the conveyor belt system that was very
critical is about four thousand pounds
an hour that this conveyor belt was was
making for the company and that had been
compromised by ransomware he noticed
this because network traffic protocol
was suddenly being used by this
controller most gated systems use GPS
not ntp they used the GPS controller
gets its time from the satellite not
from the network time protocol it was a
hacker system that was using NTP and it
was causing some bandwidth so he said
basically this ransomware got installed
on a PC because a lot of the workers
were surfing the web on the PC that was
controlling the internet control the ICS
system the the conveyor belt so the
downtime costs were very expensive four
thousand pounds in an hour
so the solution obviously get the people
to stop browsing management liked it but
the Union objected why well you can't
tell my Union people what to do right
and in other cases you might say well
that's apply to my country or whatever
but there are always cases where one
party doesn't want to do but the
security worker recommends so the
creative solution was okay we're going
to give everybody their own tablet they
can surf on that tablet the tablet surfs
gets on the internet via a completely
different network and then they stop
using that
them that was that that Windows system
that was controlling the ICS system
everybody was happy it was a
cost-effective solution so the effective
skills folks of a risk manager of a
threat hunter security analytics yeah
understanding threats they understand
endpoints they understand how to use
logging software and information event
managing software they know the business
they could do a bit of forensics they
they understand how vulnerabilities work
they can collaborate well with various
teams they can project manage themselves
and the company out of problems a lot of
soft skills folks not just technical
skills but soft skills security plus
five oh one for example is a security
plus is a certification that CompTIA
offers notice that it focuses for
example on threat attacks and
vulnerabilities a bit on tools of course
but risk management is its own approach
the whole concept folks here is of a
threat manager threat hunter of a risk
manager is that you apply these kinds of
skills so I talked to myself just a few
minutes over I think for the last 10-15
minutes we want to answer any questions
or what have you I can give other
elements of the presentation and spend
some more time but if you want there's
the latest articles and blog entries
that I've done I did a an article here a
while back
well last month using an open-source
tool it's freely available called yarra
you can use it on a Linux system or a
Windows system to do to detect malware
it's an interesting obviously malware
can be detected by antivirus but again
if the antivirus tool can find it you
can go do it as a threat hunter yourself
so there various articles that I've
written various interviews that I've
done it's not to follow me again you can
follow me on twitter at James Stanger I
often give presentations and I put them
up online so people can grab them you
can also go to CompTIA or certification
dough.com co.org and learn more about
CompTIA and also about my activities
there this year is I like to take risks
myself this is my son and I playing out
in the ocean notice the
spout there that's spouting up just
after we left that picture a big wave
came up and swept the whole thing off so
thank goodness we left in time I guess
that means I was situationally aware
does anybody have any particular
questions folks that you'd uh that you'd
like to ask first I say thank you that
was a wonderful ah
it made me would put my little blue hat
on and go out you know it is really it's
an interesting set of tools that that'd
be the spread hunter has you know and or
the risk manager has you know and it's
something that anybody can bring to the
table as long as they have a technical
the business skills business process
skills and the people skills to you know
kind of put it all together okay and as
I feel other questions I was going to
bring up is because you're talking a lot
of notes only talked about a lot of it
because you come out of there yet ah so
main versus skills you pick up in the
classroom that you can bring your
company or yourself to versus people
skills I mean obviously some of them you
need to be with you know you can't learn
something that you're actually doing it
and you do that by being in a company
working with people but certainly you
can go out there and start building
these skills as you need them what would
you suggest personally like that you
don't want to become a super sleuth you
know one of the first things is we learn
by doing so find a mentor if you can't
find somebody who engages in some of
these types of activities and a lot of
these guys tend to be a bit shy for
various reasons that just by nature I
think a lot of techies are and a lot of
them also are busy but find somebody in
the company that understands at least
the concepts and the practices and get
to know him or her and that's what I did
20 years ago I just started going in and
kind of asking questions around and and
learning more about it the other thing
that you can do is again if it's really
important to understand how business
works so learn more from non techie
people about you know how businesses
work how decisions are made in a company
and and and as you can combine that
technical in that and that business
ability you you will do well learn this
as a we are techies I asked them all on
this call we get hired for our techie
for our technical skills our techie
skills chances are we're gonna get
promoted because of our business skills
so we talk Tech and get hired and then
we get promoted because we talk and do
business you combine those and you're
there so practically first of all there
are classes we don't offer them
necessarily but there are classes in
threat hunting you can do that but get
to know people get into those circles
create a plan and then you you you could
get into these and talk with these folks
off and on you'll find that they will be
very willing to share information as
long as they as long as they don't think
you're getting they're getting packed
you know that you're trying to do
something but if you you know gain their
trust get to know them buying a coffee I
think you'll you'll be pleasantly
surprised and again we have the Q&A over
there so if you have email personal
questions a couple more here we have
time for a few more in addition to what
I got already down
you mentioned hmm oh one two for the
different levels of security and if the
cost increased goes up when you kind of
tie that into I know from more on a
different side of my own side that you
know you took the thousand light bulbs
you never gonna have a perfect thousand
light bulb light up so if you have all
the one you need to ship them out
because they'll never do business if you
wait for that last light bulb you know
in a production setup and then so can
you talk us a little bit about the cost
an amazing tip out of a turn of an 80mm
Oh from one before and how that goes up
first is taking out insurance what kind
of insurance would you even take out on
that that's a great question
you know you can find insurance
companies that will pretty much insure
anything
and and there are a couple observations
one when it comes to the risk you always
identify a resource and then you ask
yourself what will that do to my
business if it gets compromised or taken
out and then you ask yourself well if it
gets compromised you're taking out it
costs the business ten dollars
well not that big a deal okay
well we'll just we'll absorb that so you
can just absorb it just go well that's
constituting business we'll be fine if
it's something that's like we're gonna
lose a whole day of business right and
that could compromise our company to the
point where we won't be profitable that
month then you ask yourself okay how
much money does the company make in a
month
let's say it makes a million dollars in
a month right
well after employee costs after the cost
of rent the cost of doing business let's
say the company profits half a million a
month right so you then identify well
how much does it cost to replace that
system and all that you start
identifying system replacement you know
start identifying redundancy solutions
and so you basically will say well if if
there's a half a million dollars of
profit at risk here you don't want to
spend out half a million on it but
there's a percentage of that that you
will look at you will also look at the
cost of duplicating that system and if
you find that well there's it cost about
thirty thousand dollars to implement
controls or implement a backup that's a
complete backup
well thirty thousand dollars versus half
a million to reduce that risk to a point
where we really aren't worried about it
anymore that's well worth it from an hmm
from an hmm zero perspective where you
have no processes and you're just
relying on a few alerts you have to
consider the cost of getting hacked is
higher than much higher much higher than
the cost of your solutions so I would
argue that when it comes to cost of just
a few alerts you can do something and
have somebody put together a snort of a
set of alerts and things and have that
zero
hmm zero you know designation fairly
inexpensive
you know for 10 hours 20 hours of a
person's time to implement the system
that's not good enough to move from 0 to
1 I think you're going to start
implementing various intrusion detection
systems you're going to start
implementing fred hunting regimen we're
dedicated person spence aid you know 30
hours a month you know looking around
identifying problems and identifying
where things are so you know putting
together that kind of hourly rate for a
security worker and you know you're
you're in your region you will have an
idea of what that security worker will
work at how much that was security
personal cost
there's some software that you might
need to purchase a lot of open-source
software is available so start looking
at the time that the person that you're
going to rent or buy or else a rancher
buy another words higher than full time
or maybe they'll come on as a contractor
you'll need that plus you'll need to
dedicate training of existing security
workers to understand threat hunting so
you have to put together those costs
that will get you - hm-hmm one level you
start getting into the two level now
you're having to segment networks to
create resilience you're gonna have and
also better opportunities for monitoring
you're gonna have to so there's a lot of
infrastructure work by infrastructure
work i mean you can have to hire
somebody who really knows how all those
systems work together you can have to
get good scanning and vulnerability
management software and a good program
for monitoring that so now you're
talking about three times the cost i
would say of zero hm zero right i mean i
hm1 and to move in - hm - I would say
it's a it's a from suite at ten times
the cost as you move up and so you have
to ask yourself if you make a half a
million dollars a year a month how much
of that can you spend on you know moving
your way up into that spread hunter you
know being able to pivot resources
better because if you don't you'll end
up losing that
it all together so you have to get the
right percentage a lot of people will
say well a 6% margin of that 500k is
something that we would look at is
spending to make sure that we are
improving our threat hunting so there's
there's a few there's a few ideas a few
kind of a calculus of how people do
threat hunting ok those that come on
that's certainly time an exponential
growth there to higher level yeah and
there are other things you can do you
can take existing employees and turn
them into threat hunters and if you
already have a good infrastructure then
that cost is gone but most companies
don't they just don't ok and that have
we have separate me one more question
and have muhammad's I think one of the
pre requisite certifications that are
required to be a threat hunter
that's a great question you know nobody
has defined what those prerequisites are
so for me to say ok here they are and
that you know that is what you have to
be to be a threat hunter I can't say
that I would argue though that the first
thing you have to do is understand
endpoints then you have to understand
networks so you could argue a plus
network plus a plus as endpoints network
plus is networks right then you get into
security plus to understand the security
implications then you start learning
about security analytics right so our
analyst cert then you have pentesting
you learn about that and you don't have
to go the CompTIA route guys you know
you can go with sans does a great thing
with their security essentials wait a
minute what's it called security I
remember the I forget the name but there
are other organizations out there that
have great tools in regards to
penetrating in regards to penetration
testing but you you have to first take
the path of learning how a network how
endpoints work how a network operates
how business works so I would argue
understanding almost an ITIL based
approach and then understanding all the
technical elements of how business works
together a plus for endpoint network
plus for networks you know you go Cisco
I got
learn that thing I prefer a vendor
plural approach an approach that doesn't
focus on a vendor solution but focuses
on how businesses work more but but you
know there are great opportunities out
there to learn from you know Cisco
Microsoft whatever but I would argue any
program that you join that teaches
endpoints networks how security works
how analytics with pen testing those are
very important foundational things
foundational skills and the more that
you have an organization that teaches
you how things work underneath the hood
and not so much well here's how the the
software interface works or how the
actual software work you know file you
know new don't worry about that you know
file new you know open up this file and
learn more about how this vendor Tool
Works I'm not interested in that what
I'm more interested in and some of the
protocols work how do the actual
physical devices work and how do they
play well together how do they don't how
do they not play well together if you
can get a good training program that
focuses on that on solution business
based and technical based all at the
same time then you've got something that
will prepare you to be a good threat
hunter
and by the way Fred hunter again I want
to get too into this buzz phrase I'm not
a buzz term you know oh that's the
latest trend I'm interested in risk
management risk management's been a
skill and a job role or are a job skill
that's been around for hundreds of years
or you know in our lives has been around
for you know since humanity started how
do we manage risk what's the risk reward
from an IT perspective focus on how risk
management is taught and how risk
management is implemented if you can get
those skills then you're already a
threat hunter because you're going based
on what I'm looking at what is at risk
and how can I apply money the smartest
way so that I can have getting a good
return on investment and also manage
hacks so that you know we're lowering
risk and that feels really what 500 do
they go excellent excellent
the things I've noticed in all of our
technology since you know to be learning
those primary technology is the domain
it's so hard to go between the domain
which is going to be different from
their company or everywhere and the
skills you need because you have to have
the skills but then you also have to
learn the whole domain so I know whether
that you're working you know what kind
of people you work with it you're doing
that project management Sigma finding
our Sigma certification so you can work
with the people that are in foreign
teams versus you're talking about
endpoints and the technology of
networking to connect them excellent
wonderful that does bring us in univille
hour which I thoroughly enjoy even being
stuck at home I'm still ready for it I
know I think you a special thanks dr.
singer for being here with us today
happy to be here and thank you everybody
I was in India a couple of years ago now
and just thoroughly enjoyed it and so
everybody have a great evening I think
it's night time there and if you have
any questions feel free to contact me at
any of the
sources here that that we've listed you
can grab me I am me via Twitter for
example or what have you so thank you
very much everybody for your time that's
it and there are also special thanks for
simply loading for putting these
together if you want more information on
simply would do to contact them either
on their website or if you filled up the
list that they had earlier they'll send
you and you know and connect up with you
look for you soon in our classrooms and
oh they're awesome I've been working
with them for a boy over a year now and
almost a year and a half Oh excellent
thank you very much and have a good
evening good morning or afternoon hi
there if you like this video subscribe
to the simple learn YouTube channel and
click here to watch similar videos de
nerd up and get certified click here